all right
is the stream on
i think the stream is on it
and is quite all right
all right
nice
is that what we want yeah basically
stream will begin shortly okay that's
good
and it's quite alright
um
[Music]
can hear the cars in the background
my alarm to pick up
premiere will begin shortly
so the 6 45 am it's supposed to be a
countdown because it's supposed to start
at seven
um
but there's no countdown
it's just
countdown begins it's 6 45 am oh there
we go
[Music]
microsoft edge
who is ready for the elden ring reveal
also i'm not good at streaming so
hopefully this like works
like this is half decent quality
[Music]
[Music]
ten
and there's the proper countdown
got some music that's good
oh
what's good lily tarnish oh wow we got a
chatter
i don't stream so this is cool
hi calan roar hope you're doing well
bruh
also i'm not sure what the latency is so
actually let's check the volume
okay my mic is
probably still louder than the
desktop audio when i have it turned down
a little bit
count down to account dang it well there
was
i guess it wasn't a countdown we were
waiting for the countdown to start oh my
oh
that was loud
um yeah we were waiting for the
countdown to start
and yeah youtube has its own countdown
to the countdown
good memes good memes
oh
i will say i'm currently rocking one
monitor and that makes it more difficult
for sure to uh
to have all this streaming stuff ready
audio is good now good to hear thanks
for the thanks for the feedback i
appreciate it
um i streamed probably like two times
like three years ago so
i should have better mic now uh but the
streaming setup is live streaming on
youtube urban
uh because youtube playback is so much
better so i'm watching it on youtube
and
yeah string on youtube easy peasy
uh there's probably enough people
covering it on twitch so
and i don't really want to try
get
figuring how to do a streaming
do streaming is too hard actually might
not be it might be super easy i've never
done it
the only time i did stream before was
when i was on twitch
so
the time i did before was when i was on
twitch
yeah that's all right
um where is the second monitor the
second monitor is
not with me because i'm in my new place
and currently i'm just rocking one
27-inch monitor
so
doing everything on one monitor
stream-wise is a bit difficult and i
gotta make sure i don't show my
streaming key haha because streamers do
do that right
oh music died out
and i just got quieter
let's bring this down a little bit more
so i can amp it up here
all right
who is excited
weird vati isn't streaming
does he normally
stream uh releases well actually
normally there wasn't canada releases so
people aren't streaming releases um at
least in the same way uh even though i'm
not surprised vati wouldn't be because
he does everything super analysis in
depth um so i'm assuming he wants to
just make a video on it i'm gonna be
busy so i'm not gonna be have time to
make a analysis video on it which is
part of the reason why i'm streaming
um and it's a cool countdown to
get hyped
get hyped about so it's a good
opportunity for me in terms of just like
being exciting
he streamed the trailer oh well then
i'm not sure
maybe he'll come when it has five
minutes left in the countdown
um or not but i you can fully expect him
to make a long in-depth video about it
i'm sure it'll be filled with stuff that
i would say i would miss then i wouldn't
want to say the community will miss
since i would assume most of the stuff
he finds will be stuff the community
finds
um
but i haven't kept up with the stuff to
know if he is actually really good
himself at finding stuff when i like did
my
uh
my trailer analysis
uh i like spent a lot of time on the
discord
and like eighty percent of that was
probably stuff i talked about on there
i did help contribute to finding it but
nonetheless it was a definitely
community effort for my stuff
well this could be louder
so the gameplay is supposed to be 15
minutes long and also 20 minutes of dev
commentary i'm not sure how much those
overlap it could overlap completely
i would kind of assume
there would be some level of
just gameplay being shown maybe just
like a hype gameplay trailer at the very
start or maybe they replay the previous
trailer
um and then we get
uh
game dev the devs talking about
um the gameplay
and like walking us through explaining
different things
maybe they won't leave much for me to
explain and analyze also i'm not really
sure how i want to do this live so i
don't really want to pause it
uh
countdown ception j ayala very true
though now we're just at a countdown so
we're good we're just
we've left the second level of inception
and now we're just on normal countdown
or drain
yeah i don't know if i'm i don't really
want to pause it a lot and talk because
then we'll be live
um but maybe that doesn't matter too
much
or i'll just try catching up
youtube is really good at playback
because it has that beautiful two times
uh playback anytime you can jump around
and stream it's really it's really clean
which i don't watch a ton of twitch live
it's my knowledge twitch still doesn't
have that which is definitely an issue
well it says we got seven people in here
lit
thank you for coming to the hype show
everybody um i don't stream so it's cool
to get a couple people while i'm
streaming also i haven't posted
consistent videos in a long time so most
of my
um
even though i have like 20k subs it's
like eh not really
uh but it's cool to have you here i hope
you are hyped for the elden ring uh
start
we got a glimpse of mountain combat
because that has not been great in most
games
i agree with you kellen roar and i would
almost certainly bet that 15 minutes of
gameplay we should definitely see some
mountain combat in the trailer they
didn't really show much mountain combat
they showed the jumping off
um which could technically which is like
a little bit it's one aspect of mountain
combat but i'd assume in a 15 minute
gameplay reveal there's enough stuff in
there that they give us a uh
they go they give us some significant
amounts of combat
could be wrong they might not want to do
it maybe the mountain combat isn't very
good
um
[Music]
we'll see
yeah so
true
let's go
getting down to five minutes
soundtrack is very nice it's very
bells and rings and
i could if somebody just lied to me and
said this is dark souls music i would
probably believe them
i can make this false and
this is
kind of jpeg
oh it's on 720
there we go
it's a little lustery for you
all right we're getting down to it with
some epic orchestral music
probably a little loud let's check
yeah it's a little um
also i should probably just be a bit
louder so i'm gonna move my mic in a
little bit more
so the stream might be a little bit
louder overall um you guys let me know
if it's
extreme i'm assuming it's not because
normally i err on the side of too quiet
um
but if it is i can turn stuff down let
me know if the levels are weird at all
um
yeah
i was looking for the one with less
viewers
needs it hi there raphael aha
well this is a stream with less viewers
so we appreciate your company
getting excited for eldon ring 3
minutes 47 seconds away
you can see the stream delay if you see
what time it is when you heard that and
read it they
linked up
this does sound like yuka's composition
definitely a bit of the
it's been a lot of drums and definitely
a bit of the darker elements for most of
us
um
people asking for bloodborne pc oh
so demon souls the
remake that's not been on the ps5 is
probably i don't think it's been
officially announced right it's but from
the leak it's probably
coming out um
on pc
or maybe it's been confirmed since then
but bloodborne on pc would be really
nice
that would be
fire
saying to someone who's played
bloodborne but hasn't played it
too much because i haven't done much
playstation stuff
that shouldn't sound weird
well english nominated oh no uh if
you're talking about your messages
rafael no you sound totally fine you're
you
would have made me think you're a native
english speaker so
good job i will say a lot of times most
of the time people i meet that aren't
native english speakers have really good
english when they say sorry english is
in my native language um
but i also don't only speak one language
so
if you can communicate with me you speak
english pretty well because that's all i
have
or you can try latin i took latin in
high school definitely can't speak it
but have a vague idea of some of it
two minutes
music is good
i will be interested if they have a
couple compositions that are like
a little bit more different than what
we're used to in terms of dark souls
stuff
but it's also been a while
and i guess shaqiro um had a different
style of music for sure
so maybe they want to spend some time
returning to
dark souls
1 2 3 music
i don't actually know if dark souls 2 is
a bit different than one and three
because i played less of it
i almost beat it i got up to the final
boss and i died like twice
and i really don't want to make that
boss run back again because i have a big
issue with boston backs
and haven't beaten him
just too bad
kind of a meme
museum the museum associates hi uh the
next non-latin speaker what's the story
with this please explain
um
well thank you luigi sure thing raphael
same finish bloodborne didn't play dlc
yeah i didn't play any dlc i really want
that as well and museum associates i'll
explain in the 50 seconds we have left
this is eldon ring this is uh the next
from software game if you heard dark
souls uh i would assume you would know
what it is if you're here maybe you're
just a subscriber who hasn't watched
dark souls content
um
got em
uh
this is eldon ring the next from
software game the people who made dark
souls it's a they work with george r
martin to make the story it's kind of
like a
gothic
medieval inspired fantasy inspired uh
action rpg i think is the classification
um and yeah it's known for being very
hard and has lots of lore and is a very
fun experience this is the gameplay
reveal
trailer or not reveal but a 15 minute
look at gameplay and we only have five
more seconds so
let's go
oh the stream quality just dipped a lot
still on 1080p
peggy 16. there we go
hello everyone
thank you for taking the time to join us
today that could be louder in this video
we'll show some footage of our new
action rpg eldon ring see told you it
was an action rpg i hope it helps to
convey a little of this title's mood and
gameplay
i hope it does too
oh
elden ring is set here let me know if
the audio is good this is pretty quiet
this is a sight of grace
acting as a place of rest for the player
okay a set of braces or bonfires
occasionally grace will manifest the
fires of guiding light
oh
oh that was fluid of course we're free
to choose whether to follow this
guidance or head off to explore in a
different direction
oh oh there are bonfire signifiers um
not sure if i like that also i don't
know how much of this is already
revealed since i haven't been super keen
up to date so
you'll have to let me know
no problem museum associates
well cal and rohr we're getting uh
oh
familiar death sound
and we're getting some mounted gameplay
if not combat
okay and they got this
magic staff out of the spear for a
second
well magic is definitely going to be
what you want to do on horseback
oh
triple bow that's what we like to see
maybe raise it up a notch
the gameplay
i can definitely do that
all right brought it up should be nice
and loud and proper
oh
visceral attacks
i like knockdowns
and the energy the glowing energy in the
boss that we saw in its eye right there
that was clean
all right good and thanks for all the
feedback calendar it's appreciated in
getting the basic stream to work oh pop
boys
oh my stars i'm so happy to see you
i am alexander
also known as the iron fist
and as you can see i'm stuck here
please
can you help me out of this
that looks really good put those doubts
to rest i'll be just fine
i'm very well trained
give it your all i say
do you think this is
oh
it's probably pop boy talking it's
probably not a dude in it it's probably
just the pot
well played good sir welcome
oh that mighty wallop of yours almost
spelled the end of me
this is a meme
oh oh
oh i almost don't even want to see this
because it's so beautiful i want to see
in game there's two herb trees
or two earth tree tree like things and
we're taking out of that golden trees
there's three of them
the map can prove useful when exploring
the world and is populated by acquiring
map fragments
that's different
we can use markers to customize the map
such as setting reminders for the
location of crafting materials or
dangerous enemies
i might be okay with this
the map is really cool i'm not sure i
feel about it in terms of never knowing
where you are
beacons can also be placed to help with
orientation
four trees on that
beacons placed on the map appear in the
world
that's it's different five for sure
they're big open world i i get it but
i said there'll be six areas yeah
oh
spirit springs can be used while on
horseback to launch high into the air
this allows for a stress-free traversal
of areas with a great deal of
verticality i do
verticality movement is really good we
like that dark souls one yeah so height
a large part because it had really good
verticality
riding around hitting like settlements
of
these are not hollows in this game
monsters
eagles are cool
i wonder if they'll have any
significance past just being cool eels
they seem a little bit more significant
at the exact same binocular
they'll look more like a mono
monocular
monoscope double zoom carriage over
there is carrying treasure
an opportunity too good to pass up the
the horse all the horizontal stuff does
look super prepared for combat with some
item crafting using materials found in
the world
crafting from materials
okay
they're taking on the open world
crafting
also iffy on that
a stealth boat kill
i do like that
oh my god and the assassinate
i wouldn't have thought they took more
stealth stuff than
security
enemy stones can be broken with
a variety of unique attacks can also be
interchanged between weapons
well it is looking pretty clean
what's the loot
oh they don't show us what the loot is
in more perilous situations we can
summon spirits to assist us in battle
one miller
spirits vary greatly and tight so we
look forward to players experimenting
and finally
oh
yeah i recently played through star wars
fallen order
i don't know if this looks more secure
than dark souls it definitely takes a
lot from sakiro i'm not sure if i would
say more there's so many things in this
that are just so
so dark souls but maybe i'm just a
biased in that
online multiplayer can also be enjoyed
with players from other worlds from
cooperative to pvp and invasions
a lot of the sword playing different
weapons just makes me think so dark
souls this looks really nice
dual haliburt or dual pike
oh wow they have a semi-normal voice
saying hey
hello
some more blue
stones
those deadly creatures stalk this forest
yeah
to avoid detection
definitely playing into more stealth
which could be could definitely be cool
as a new
extra
mechanic
now you can get around big bads a new
way that's cool it's good
suppose you're just stumbling
with that and the jump you should be
able to like move her oh we've come
across a boss guarding this area oh
we'll take it on with the help of
alcohol
i think they blocked that first attack
which seemed pretty like a
keto parrot
all right
oh
oh
you just have eldritch's aldrich's
attack
oh my god
oh yeah
they have dragon heads
the fairy on this is dying
soul stream
looking beautiful
no fall damage
well let's see fall
that wasn't very much
well that was pretty pretty
no fault energy
maybe it's just fall damage if you die
enough to kill you but no full damage
unless
cat ring
kind of deal
definitely a lot less than dark souls in
any
way
hello jay ayala
nice to have you here
catacombs caves mayans and other
dungeons can be found while out
exploring the world
these are possibly like very expensive
legends each hold their own secrets from
hidden treasures to fears and bosses
oh they got the cape on with the sword
emblem
oh illusory walls wow
that dude just showed it though
oh
wow that's just the exact
same
exact same chess
the landing text doing yeah i don't know
the red the red of the red lightning was
definitely very notable i wonder if it
had any special significance
oh
fire keeper shows up to any
bonfire
greetings
traveler
from beyond the fog
i am melaner
reddish hair
i
offer you an accord
and they scarred
our tattooed
eye
we've reached stormville cost wonder
what the
dungeon which connects seamlessly with
the surrounding limb grave region
limb grave region
sounds like an adjective but i think
they're using the proper noun limb grave
come over here
return of creepy npcs
you're tarnished aren't you
i would advise against taking the main
gate into the castle
it's tightly guarded by hardened old
hands
oh
try the opening right here
gods don't know about it
you breach the castle undetected
will i
okay no sigma i'll use the main entrance
fair enough
you certainly don't have to trust me
well if you must go through the gates
i'll signal them to open
oh what of course i'd advise against it
yeah boyzatkin is really good
ella
wow this guy just doesn't care
no i don't want to die
i'm the killer i'm the tarnish
looking sexy
giant
good name
the main route seems risky so we'll try
entering through a back way yeah
oh parkour you just don't pick up the
item
i don't want to show us any item pickups
oh
that's clean
i'm normally not a big magic or miracle
user i'm definitely going to be using
some of those summons
power attacks break their poise
oh
them using the spells weapons whatever
they are
i like that
killing enemies
or being around the world can get you
the return of estes
extra care should be taken when moving
through dungeons as visibility and
terrain differ from when in the open oh
it's visibility everybody players enjoy
getting a feel for the different types
of areas and coming up with suitable
strategies for each
oh
well i guess we know that
that surprise tag is going to be there
unless they change it for the main game
look around your corners everybody
lots of fade to blacks in this trailer
bro that outfit for the tarnished it's
clean
i say that right as it gets dark and you
can't see all the colors but
well jumping around in the world to like
find stuff
is going to be really cool
like sneak around to see what paths are
actual paths and
what paths just get you killed jumping
and then falling
yeah it is like these dungeons are
complex and multi-layered meaning they
can be tackled from a number stabbed
with a short knife in your bag
big hat
ah
nice to meet you
the pleasure's mine
roger is the name roger
as
you might have guessed
i'm looking for a little something not
roger's big head well i'm not
hot-footing it from the troops that is
but enough about me
what are you doing here in stormdale
castle stormville's
trees are big in this game trees were
big in previous games oh
hey is that
looks like me
is that a tarnish hunter
they have the big eagle i'm assuming
that's a tarnished hunter there are
people specifically going after us to
grab
that sounds like using something with
the many
trees maybe the ones that are like herd
trees
i like the uh butterfly trees and dark
souls 3.
we challenge one of the demigods
ruler of stormville godric the golden
godric the golden ruler of stormville
little spoilers but you're watching a 15
minute gameplay reveal i guess that's to
be expected
i can see them ending it here mighty
dragon
dirty
air
lend me thy strength o kindred
deliver me unto
greater heights
another guy obsessed with dragons well
tarnish is here to mess your day up
i command thee
i
am the lord of all that is
golden isn't that just lord raven
did he get the name wrong
oh he looks so small all the way over
there
weapon and views to the thing
they
oh you can summon a big man
i wonder if you only get like one of
those summons per life for what the
limitations
[Music]
oh my god this dude is super agile
i thought our guy died there
i'm assuming it'll die from that
looks like a lot of damage
thank you for watching now
this was just a brief introduction to
eldon rings fundamentals i guess that
was pretty more details will be revealed
at a later date
there's not long to go now before
release
true in the meantime we greatly
appreciate your continued support
the tarnished will soon return and now
they play the
trailer again
someone must extinguish
thy flame
to be born
[Music]
might be way other than just dying
bitrate
okay
pre-order now and get a digital
adventure guide and bonus gesture wow a
digital guy
exclusive steel book collectors edition
wow
premium collector's edition
it's like legendary version of halo 3
you get a little helmet i wonder if
that's
they said it was a one-to-one
maybe you could actually wear that
how would you guys think that is have
they released the price on that it's
probably like 150 bucks
thank you for watching
well
there's the trailer
looks like they're evading bloodborne
sick thanks for the stream yeah thanks
for stopping by calendar i really
appreciate it
thanks for streaming commenting luigi
yeah thank you raphael thanks everyone
for checking it out i'm probably going
to be reviewing it a bit more if you
want to stick around but if you're
heading out thanks for watching helmet
is tight
tight isn't cool or tight as in it's
tight in your head
got him
from soft magnum opens well we'll have
to see
there are a lot of like
critical things okay can we not can we
not get a pewdiepie ad for an autoplay
another video
um
oh stream
oh i better not have screwed myself
um can i can i replay this video now
thank you very much
thank you all right youtube is good like
that
we almost were screwed
yeah oh appreciate it raphael
hope it fits it's not too tight yeah
well i'm gonna do press get those copies
early too we'll be able to say if
anybody has a
any idea on how actually tight it is it
was a one-to-one i'm assuming it's
well people are different size heads so
this is
the person
we see that shows up in the trailer that
we kneel to i'm assuming they're the
leader of covenant considering they got
a mask
um look a little religious
um
and what was it
i think it's what the queen also wears
masks so maybe it's some
relation to the
that body of people
but they're on your side and you're
fighting the queen so maybe you can join
the covenant and it's not
it's not like fighting for the queen but
who knows
lots of trees though a lot of them look
smaller than the archery we don't see
big trunks like we do with the er tree
um big cracked leaning trunks
um
yeah let's just i'll just probably be
hopping around through it and stopping
and seeing what we see
this is a site of grace
acting as a place of rest for the play
and one thing about the side of grace is
that
you can see
all like the pedals and stuff around
here they said sight of graces will
sometimes have things that show where
they are so i'm assuming once you start
seeing the petals you know there's one
near you as opposed to having like a big
marker in the air that'd probably be a
better way to do it
occasionally grace will manifest rays of
guiding light oh
no
rays of guiding light so that just tells
you where to go of course we're free to
choose as opposed to
it being uh
showing where it is
okay
and this is kind of the
entry area we saw before we got a
steeple a little place to check in
that is
[Music]
has a goat
yeah it looks like just like a normal
goat
i wonder if you interact with normal
goats at all
all right well direction
more of the little church broken down
settlement
these are the people on the road there's
a little watcher up here i don't know if
he's related
um or somebody who just sits in the area
and shouts if you cross the road
lots of little dudes in the back
following holding banners they have
weapons but they look more like just
zombie peasants as opposed to like
important people
um there's a knight here so a couple
nights in the front and then the big
boys
the other we the settlement that they
attack of this had treasure in the back
here so i don't know if they'll all have
treasure any of them have important
people or what or what the treasure is
because they didn't show us
more little dudes
there's a wall for the road we get big
herd tree and small tree tree
we don't have a name for those right i
don't think we do
oh you can just ride around them if you
don't want to attack
oh there was another
this guy
i'm assuming an enemy encampment that
looks
i i'm going to assume enemy could be
something else because there's just one
guy with a banner
but
yeah not sure
now
this i'm not sure
would we call this a swamp the water
looks pretty clean i'm gonna say this is
not
uh
not quite a swamp but that we should
expect this one it's poor tree men
playing that wagon yeah though even if
they get free they use that big uh spike
as an attack right so
they're not too poor
um
what is this
this is like a ball
of like flesh
it almost looks like a heart
i went back too far
i must it looks kind of like something
that explodes if you get too near but i
can't really tell
a bunch of dudes around a bonfire
look like they're afk
set piece to get killed by this dragon
that sound is just like it used to be
the dragon destroyed the fire
interesting
we get the back side of
that little ball
and now it looks more inert
oh mate maybe it's a dragon egg but it's
so just weird and out in the middle of
nowhere
they're also this seems like a big
statue of a person i don't know i don't
feel like i've seen that before
um
you guys can let me know if you have we
see a
backside shot of one of the other trees
more of its trunk so maybe that's more
developed than a lot of the other
smaller ones we've seen
and statue
dragon egg ball of flesh
dragon looks like it has some feathers
yeah definitely definitely feathered
which i feel like we haven't seen
dragons before
egg reminds you of fillianor
could be but it also seems like
really randomly placed to be something
important like at all so i feel like it
isn't important but that it looks like a
dragon egg so i don't know
it's paid to black of course
the sky is very
color of the tree
i don't know the error tree reaches up
and touches the clouds so it makes sense
um darker here lighter here oranger
bluer
is this the direction of the earth tree
a lot of these trees are leafless i
don't know if that means they're dead
some of them there's some life though
this this body of water does have some
life around it lots of the blue flowers
uh not dead swampy
spell
spell casting multiple trees in the back
big
um er tree looking like it has more of
the blue aura so when you get farther
away from that you get more orange maybe
some birds in the sky
there will definitely be stuff i miss in
this trailer but just going through it
to see
what i can catch
this is so we see the
um
broken walkway and tower that we see
from the
opening shot i don't know about what i
would call opening shot of the original
trailer or like the first where you go
out and see the world um so we are in
the foreground of that shot with the
dragon and the blue water
hard to say you'll find out sooner or
later absolutely beautiful environment
yeah the world looks really cool
um graphics wise people were concerned
because it wasn't
like super hyped because
it was being made for old consoles as
well which i still would say i would
like to see it not made for old consoles
because i think it would have been
even better looking but the like world
design and visual design looks very very
good and the graphics look like they
very much do their job to
convey the beauty of the world of the
world and visual design
made the black
again in this area broken either tombs
or buildings
in the water we're still in this
foreground
there was the one the golden castle area
i forgot what that's called
um
to the left which matches up with that
earlier shot so now it's a little bit
more orange
near the earth tree and blue away from
the archery
dragon breathing fires dragons do
kind of missing us completely though
cringe do you not even see us
us with the
beautiful
mongolian
archer horseback maneuver
four magical homing arrows looks like
they
pack a punch but the dragon did not care
and wearing some broken down ruins
something to
another shot of the tree
dragon getting pissy
i just wanted to see one thing
now that i'm gonna say if this looks
like a person
or
i think they're tree stumps
i think i think they're just tree stumps
it could be a person it's a little
drapey but i'm gonna go with tree stones
for now
blood splatter
decked by the dragon dragon has pretty
cute eyes looks like a
cute little animal or old man
that's me skipping ahead yeah it was
oh
i feel like we've moved back and there's
another one of these little egg things
filling the animation looks so smooth
they really couldn't measure it from
somewhere yeah looks it looks really
good um
yeah i'm very excited about it i think
fromsoft did a really good job but we'll
have to see how a lot of the new
mechanics and workings will like
crafting the map because that is going
into into the world of more other open
world games which i've gotten pretty
played out with collecting materials
crafting to a map that said um it wasn't
the most recent but i've been playing
through metro exodus and that's another
game they took from more linear into
open world though dark souls wasn't
linear in the same sense
and i think they did a good job of that
though maybe collecting materials and
that gets a little boring but it looks
like it'll be a little bit more
interesting than this because they're
more specific materials but that could
also make it more annoying to get go
find those materials we'll see
breathing fire
i wonder if all like the feathers and
stuff to note that this is a younger
dragon
these are some full on feathers
there's the
mounted gameplay that's
calling roar said he wanted or she or he
bae sorry
so they wanted to see maps so also
special with these markers yeah true
now also the design the design of the
map looks really cool
big hit
and then what i noted before
so there's golden aura this seems to be
a thing in a lot of the creatures like
where they get their power from and
possibly where we get our power from to
some element of that so maybe it's not
souls in this game but this is some sort
of
ant element or entity or
energy that gives us power
when you kill the dragon it loses it so
or it looks like it died but then it
kind of got back up so maybe it's only
one eye out hello
can you hear me
help me i'm stuck
hello
also
i don't know if this
is a completely separate area or
somewhere that we've kind of seen where
i'd be kind of surprised if there's
dynamic weather so i'm assuming this is
like you get into some area and the fog
sets in
windy
i really like
this guy looks clean
it's a pretty neutral color set but it
looks clean
also this is very prominently the sigil
of the uh tree group
so pots or trees i'm so happy to see
spots are group tree i am alexander
also known as the iron fist
alexander the iron fist
these can you help me out i didn't
realize the gameplay was already out if
i was being streamed later today
well connor straight yeah
was trained
um 30 minutes ago and now we're going
back through the stream
and watching and analyzing
this is alexander the iron fist or a pot
ah
well played good sir well
it's cool we got some friendly pots for
sure oh that mighty wallop of yours
almost spelt the end of me
great voice acting
very short look at pop boy
this
is very beautiful
again we got some trees
church on the hill
big super church
misty crap
missy lair this could be the big
uh
kind of amphitheater dome thing we've
seen before i'm not sure this is an
intact structure
this seems to be something of
significance big open circle
um
i'm not sure what
fog lands with ruins
maybe these are probably just trees
maybe some houses
broken
um
yeah i'm not sure
oh and it looks like there's these could
be more rocks they look a little bit
different could be a uh
castle up there
top probably must be the volcano yeah
yeah
that is probably that that is the
description that
uh
well
um
cool garb got your
gem
duel not scimitars but curved swords
walkway golden light
maybe the urge tree is behind us to the
right
and here's the map
so a tree
doesn't look necessarily super big
okay the youtube bar is in the way but
place beacon back open mark
marker menu site of graceless you see
all your graces show multiplayer status
zoom help
okay so there is a time and there could
be uh
weather as well
or signify weather
i like the old vibe of the map
i wonder if you'll
these look
i'm going to say these look like places
you can travel but i don't think so i
love the art style of the map yeah i
really like it
um
definitely makes you feel like your
character is holding a map as opposed to
some random in-game thing
these are i'm assuming the tree for
these are tree look like tree fragments
they said there were map fragments
um
this is a notable place
we have a telescope here
i wonder if this will mean anything like
oh you can find treasure here i'm
assuming there's not a lot of going
across the water but
more fragments
more significant location ruins this is
the same as this so maybe it's a
repeatable thing
this is big green tree which is same as
we found here
the map can prove useful when exploring
the world
more
branch fragments
okay this
kind of looks like that initial area
tower
um the broken walkway and the castle
golden castle area that you can swim
maybe travel the bow too
well i know you needed passage from what
was it the endless fog the endless sea
i'm terrible at remembering the proper
names um
to get to this land but maybe within
this land you can
i'd be kind of surprised if they had
swimming just from from south but maybe
they do
and boats could be more possible we saw
stone structure ruins here this looks
more wooden house that's less of a ruin
and is populated by acquiring map
fragments
app is populated by acquiring map
fragments so like these are sections
maybe you only get it when you
get to that places tree um it'd be cool
if there was a way to collect it that
wasn't just getting to places maybe like
hollow knight did well you get to a
place and you search it out
there's a missing fragment here
i don't know if this means the player
since when they opened the map the
player was in a different area
no this is probably the player looking
out on here
see what am i i'm at 18 seconds
so they're looking out at the beginning
with two arching areas
yeah and this is the circle yeah so this
is where the player is this is where the
player is right here
so we're going to see the map version of
that
here is here that's the player
so this is the area after the big castle
um well like the golden castle we see in
the start is right here once you get out
of that
then you see this area oh no then you
see this area
they must add swimming they implemented
it with sakira and it worked really well
just the headless underwater
yeah true it wasn't sakiro and they
brought in stealth and they made it more
impactful than this so they yeah they
definitely could fair point
all right let's keep looking at the map
all right um another
it looks like a nail but also looks like
an observatory not observatory telescope
pointing up
um so there's this circle there are more
of these circles on this area so maybe
they have some significance to like this
castle and this overall area
dilapidated water ruins another tree
now this this coloration that makes me
think swamp
because it's the green in the blue
but
this this feels really swampy but let's
see
kinds of markers we can use see
um
combat death person npc
animal
goat
materials different kinds of materials
house
um some sort of shelter
tree so the different the different big
trees
um banner so certain
groups sigils for like different kinds
of groups or some faction and then
i don't know a different kind of house
stronghold oh no this is probably chest
and this is house
telescope like simple which command the
stars yeah
good note good note um
obvious definitely something significant
just hard to tell what and it looks like
it's more part of the map than like
these things
like it's like like the tree
sorry about the background noise
it is rush hour and all the cars are
going to work use markers to customize
the map
such as setting reminders for the
location of crop
big
big
castle rafting materials or dangerous
enemies
dangerous enemies
big clearing kind of this looks like
this looks like could be a
broken tree with all the well now all of
these kinds of fragments are farther
down
yeah it could be
these these look like wood or stone
fragments
and this is the top left of the map so
that's the one
area sectioned off
any more beacons can also be placed to
help with
so it keeps going another tree
another circle area
i have no idea what these circles are
like to continue here but i have an
appointment nice to be here thank you
see you around yeah raphael thanks very
much for coming by being an active chat
member first time really streaming so
appreciate the engagement and yeah good
good questions comments especially about
all the elden ring stuff
see you around and
yeah excited about eldon ring with
oriental good appointment
that's the beacon
oh maybe that cracked area that's that
volcano type
thing like structure that we see
useful when exploring the world that we
see
here
oh let me close the map
beacons placed on the map
yeah they show for quite quite a range
appear in the world
i don't think i missed anything before
this
though it kind of looked
so there's no streaks around the horse
now
i i just want a double no that was a
sprint so the horse definitely has a
sprint i don't know if we saw that
before
you can see the player's arm go down to
make it go
that's a sprint
jump oh
spirit spells can be used while on
horseback to launch high into the air
let's watch that one this allows for
stress-free
that feels grand spirit springs can be
used while on horseback to launch high
into the air and i will know
the sky looks very blue right now
it doesn't have really any of that
yellow or even orangey
color it had before
so this is
excuse me
this could be like before that so it's
still
bam
uh before some
world shifting event happens from soft
light experience
can be used while on horseback to launch
high be used
one more time just to see what was
around
um
so it looks like we got some castle type
stuff in the background
we got that big crater
uh area so this could be follow this is
following the
right path
so the er tree is kind of
it's in the middle top section of the
map because right now this looks like
we're following
the path on the right we saw before so
let me bring up the map
looks like we're following this
so the er tree is up here
that section of the map
big water
horseback to launch high into the air
this
more little trees
freezing the urge tree is like the top
middle
areas with a great deal
full of verticality
the map the map does look pretty massive
the horse so the horse will definitely
help with that we'll see if it feels
teemy and alive or kind of sparse
another
this is a a ram
lightning striking down
one of the dudes that normally has the
spear in his stomach i think
more animals maybe you the animals are
some sort of cracking supply
oh and that flower that we just saw
right
behind this goat
this
this is probably a crafting material
a
garbo looking settlement right in front
of a castle gate
and they have a sigil that
looks
tree-like but not like the tree sigil so
maybe it's the sigil that the person on
the uh zoom in come on zoom in
maybe it's the sigil that we see on our
cape later on
i don't know why we attacked the
carriage over there is carrying treasure
an opportunity too good to pass up
treasure that you're not gonna let us
thin animal bones well that answers that
you can
kill goats for
for uh materials
and let's see we have level 23 runes
held so they're called the runes in this
game
um vigor mind endurance strength
dexterity intelligence faith arcane
so miracles
spells magic not sure
and i haven't played enough of
all the dark souls to know if arcane or
something like hurricane was in
any of the others like uh
maybe like uh
demon souls
um
there's equip load poise discovery
memory slots
i'm assuming these are your summons or
not the some well like the spell summons
so you have two slots oh maybe arcane is
for that so intelligence is for magic
faith is for miracles and arcane is the
amount of slots you get to summon those
white apparitions
to help fight
and store 600 of these 40 of them
throw out enemy to inflict damage
oh that's
these bone knifes you make bone knives
out of thin animal bones
intelligence dexterity strength of
course endurance yes mind i don't
actually
so mine could be replacing
what i not in vitality maybe vitality
so that's equip load but mine seems kind
of odd for that maybe it would affect
poise mine just seems like intelligence
but i'm not sure
endurance mind vigor runes held level
you know
you
items
berries
i don't actually know these are the
different all the different crafting
items maybe
um different kinds of arrows spectral
arrows
color stones
this is probably a
weapon imbuing these are bombs or these
are small bombs
um these are big bombs
this could be a homeward bone
i'm not sure
combat
switch display switch view with some
item crafting using materials found
bone arrow
flight pinion found by hunting birds
maybe you hunt those eagles
and in the world
trina's lily exceedingly rare to find
sleep bone arrow
feathered animal bone arrow with
sedative tip okay sleep arrows
well they're definitely
introducing their take on a lot of
uh
a lot of kind of developed open world
crafting mechanics so we'll we'll see
we'll see for sure
uh oh yeah and hbfp stamina very
standard
do you seem well if trina's lily are
actually really hard to find this seems
hard to make
30 of them do you do get 10 of them
so that first arrow we saw them attack
with was a sleep arrow
stealth archer sleep arrow wow
stealth archer build incoming stealth
our trophy
so the
arrow disappeared i'm assuming you don't
get them back though
enemy stance can be broken with heavy
strikes such as when attacking from
above
so
you can whack there poise
this kind of weapon art it like color
wise looks like the apparitions you
summon so much that makes me think
arcane could affect this as well
it's a really
cool
quick attack variety of attacks can also
be interchanged between weapons yeah
those are the unique
the unique interchangeable
weapon skills of the game
which i think you collect or you unlock
oh
i did not notice that i was looking away
when that happened in the trailer before
that invisible attack
that is really cool
i don't know if it has much effect since
you're like charging anyways but
i don't show you what it is
this reminds me of the deep
the cathedral of the deep and
a lot from dark souls 3.
now we're in the encampment more proper
situations
so use a belt some of the spirits to
assist us in battle
summon spirits so i'm assuming that
works very greatly and tight
this this looks really nice i want to
get this
so we look forward to players
experimenting and finding their personal
favorites
personal favorite spirits yeah there are
jump attacks okay
just like when you're in combat jump
slam down attack
boys broken
killed
familiar death sound
oh this looks like uh
another npc
windmills sky's yellow now
much more
fall
orange
colored area
oh no this guy is good no he's holding
this looks like he's not dead
i don't think a summon
not a bonfire but online multiplayer can
also be
i don't know
i don't know if this is as homey as a
bonfire since it looks like a bonfire
that just went out
now there's a piece of
grace but maybe that's kind of the point
these tiles have
i don't feel like i've seen this symbol
before
but very
somewhat celtic in terms of the
concentric circles it gives me a little
bit of that vibe
enjoyed with players from other world
statues one broken
lady
your trait person holding a sword
guarding wherever you're walking out
from from cooperative to pvp and
invasions
this looks pretty barbarian-ass clothing
all the windmills are tattered
the orange is very pretty
hey
listen
the armor that your players wearing i
really like
i like like
oh look at here
your ankle broke
you see that
that oh
[Music]
yeah that
i would hope that changes a little bit
that looks like your foot is broken
spear in one hand a magic stab in the
other
big jump
sneaking from the cthulhu
technical monster monster so we'll use
stealth
the lighting is
the video has some like quality issues
but for visual design of the lighting
looks really nice
this looks like it'll be really fun to
play through
big tree
but it doesn't have any of the glow
as some mushrooms growing on it
dude
monster dude is doing something by it
can't really tell what
poor gesture
we've come across a boss guarding this
area
we'll take it on with the help of our
little golden shard over here
it's a pretty white weapon
oh maybe this is just special
interesting this is a
nice that should be the fog wall but for
this ball
this this attack like aldrich's from
versus three this is really cool be
really strong against
red lightning is something we've seen in
a couple different enemies i think in
other trailers
very cool effect
yeah
soul stream looking
great
bird trees guys back to being blue
a non-destroyed chapel
i'm sure somebody will or lots of people
in the community will spend a lot of
time mapping out where each of these
things are
as best we can on the map
seems like an end to fall damage or at
least to medium minor fall damage
with the jumps you do it does feel like
seem like it feels a lot lighter
airier
than
falling in dark souls before it felt
really
heavy
which had its benefits um also had its
drawbacks
that would be really cool turning that
on
uh lit the candles mines and other
dungeons can be found while out
exploring the world that'd be a nice
touch
someone um
noted that earlier in the stream
i think it was calenror
the
skeleton's little head top
pretty cute
these dungeons each hold their own
secrets from hidden treasures to fierce
bosses hidden treasures to fearsome
bosses these guys have a
black aura around them which didn't look
like the other skeleton had it
and they're going to be
dungeon traps which would be cool to get
around this platforming and running
around should be a little bit better
so this was the emblem i was talking
about that those tents might have but
they did not look quite like it
this is a very this seems to be a very
obvious illusory wall i gotta say
oh purple flower that's alive it
probably signifies something what i
don't know
um
looks a little like pot but not quite
pot like pop boy
this seems like a very significant altar
area and of course they don't show us
what the item is
alas
one second
um
just checking in make sure things are
going well all right continue
this trick just apparates
a little like your horse
in terms of the color effects but now
she seems like completely here
greetings i wonder how she has that
power
kind of power from beyond the fog beyond
the fog
she's a ring lina
milliner
i
offer you an accord
almost silver hair
olive
ish colored eyes i say almost silver
hair before i said i noted um reddish
hair uh red hair seems to be somewhat
important
reddish silver hair
a closed eye with
i can't tell what this is a claw
doesn't look like a wings but a three
prong claw
offering us an accord
fade to black
we've reached stormville castle stormed
a large-scale dungeon which connects
seamlessly with the surrounding limb
grave region oh okay that
that's the emblem that was on
those banners it was the lion but it was
just like
very
airy almost i don't know how to describe
how it's
like not super fully colored through
limb grave region limb grave region
so each section of the map that like you
get a map dragon before i'm gonna assume
has its own uh
name so this is lim grave
bonfire point of grace i'm going to call
him bonfires for a long time
this looks kind of like a skull
i'm assuming this is ah
i'm to assume that's unintentional
and there's books destroyed crap
we see later on one of the dudes that
grabs us and stabs us i think is
uh
the same kind of
outfit looking as this guy
this guy's chill
you're tarnished aren't you
these this looks very tricky
it gives off kind of a prisoner vibe
but maybe this has something to do with
locking them up but i don't know it
doesn't seem too locked to the castle
it's tightly guarded by hardened old
hands
oh there's bloody feet right
the gods here know about it
you'll breach the cause the crap at hand
doesn't look like there's another hand
there
fair enough
a game
state this guy has good advice
also he tells him to open the gate so
he's like chill with him
or he just can speak
so we can expect a ballista shot
very red fire
oh
triple blissed a shot i was expecting it
was still caught a little after
erect
shooting out like a shotgun
semi-auto
the main route seems risky
try entering through a back way pick up
the item oh
um we see
kind of like that statue before
oh
actually i'm not sure
it was just broken or a lady holding up
a sword or torch
and
he's kind of like a mountain
castle looks like it's part of a
different area
that's a super cool attack
oh one thing but these guys
they have some thorns on them
i can't tell if that's
oh
i can't solve that's growing
or just thorns
looks like it could be growing with
trees being such a big thing in this
game
but it also looks like thorns
could be growing thorns as opposed to
just spikes like a
kirk was it
that's collecting the runes when they
die which is this game souls
peaks of peaks of the other area
your boy has a wind attack
you can block
so you can hyper armor attacks we we
just saw
tank the attack and just hyper armor
through it bam
didn't let that stop
and these are like the guy that gave us
the tip
yeah see they got the same thing
they have rings on their head which
makes them seem noble
um
but
the neck i don't know seems less like a
weight around their neck
extra
that should be taken when moving through
dungeons as visibility and terrain
differ from when in the open
visibility and terrain so people attack
you from shadows and terrain
i'm gonna assume sometimes some of these
crack and break hopefully players enjoy
getting a feel for the different types
of areas and coming up with suitable
strategies for each
correct
big blood explosion
obsessive arm guy
looks a little bit like dances arena um
mixed with whatever
that mean boss from dark souls one
like polly something
pammy party
probably want a cracker
uh who's just a meme
and
maybe also because he had masks in
multiple of them i'm thinking that
well it reminds me a little bit of that
lots of dead bodies of those guys we
fought in the catacombs not the cat
comes the rafters
ramparts
rooftop parkour
oh i keep doing that sorry
um
area i think we were in before that we
dropped down in that we see
the
big hat dude
the earth tree
so maybe over here is the left side of
the map and right here is the right side
of the map and there are trees in the
middle because before i was thinking the
error tree was in the top middle of the
map so these are this is the top right
and top left
do not hold me to that though
and this is the area we just saw so we
were just up here walking around
and
this was the
dungeons
meaning they can be tackled from a
number of routes a decently non-decrepit
church cathedral
and we find our boy this is another one
of those noble-esque people
long neck
and praying
uh it looks looks like a tree growing
i'm not sure it's a tree full tree we
catch any of it when we fall
i don't think we do but
yeah we don't
um
see a little more it's a person with a
sword holding down like some of the
statues we saw before
nice to meet you
the pleasure's mine
roger is the name roger sorcerer as
you might have guessed
i'm looking for a little something
here in the castle
when i'm not hot-footing it from the
troops that is but enough about me
what are you doing also these people are
holding
like tree branches
which look a little bit like the
branches
that we saw on the map
they're in stormdale castle
this place is bristling with tarnish
hunters you know
they sacrifice our kind
for grafting
they oh so maybe
they sacrifice our kind for
this person doesn't super look tarnished
maybe they are
so looks like they are sacrificed
these
could be heads as opposed to like buds
on the tree
sacrifice the tarnished for grafting so
maybe all those trees throughout the
game they're trying to make another tree
because it's broken
and they use the tarnished to graft on
to make the tree
hey
what are you doing here in stormville
castle
this place is bristling with tarnish
hunters you know yeah
they sacrifice our kind
for grafting
exactly a place i'd stroll into without
a purpose in mind hey so why are you
here he's that guy said our kind so he
should be tarnished too
i'm gonna assume this is one of the
hunters
because he just named it and
we're sporting their gear
so what is that shield
let me see that shield again
um
this actually could have been what i saw
before
is this the lion
looks kind of seahorsy
or maybe thorny like the thorns we saw
on the other
smaller versions of this guy
um lots of trees trees are a really big
theme in dark souls or from soft games
the branches
let me get a shot of it probably not
the branches are
vines surrounding the statue or like
enveloping it
a little bit here they're they're
holding the trees
really big entries
trees are what makes sense given the
urgent this next the central focus of
the game
we challenge one of the demigods
ruler of stormvale godric the golden
demigod
big tree big tree big tree
dead trees
oh is this the dragon that we killed
we fly back here
it kind of looks like this pole is is
through the dragon though
okay he has the feathers
mighty dragon
dirty
air
through earth high strength o kindred
deliver me
lend me thy strength o kindred maybe
the dragon was injured from us
or it could just be another dragon um
and they did some stuff to kill it to
take its power because we see later that
he has the dragon head
take me on to greater heights he has an
extra finger
golden
chain
very chain leaky chain
that same kind of celtic
circles not circles but intertwining
these are normal hands so he gets normal
arms from things and puts them on his
body can't really tell what this is
i
am the lord of all that is golden
lord of all that is golden well maybe
that makes him think he's the lord of
the archery
loud little operatic
got the weapon in view
just misses
so when he activates the wind he gets
super acrobatic
there's a tinge of purple on this one as
opposed to the other ones that were more
white i don't know if i'm misremembering
or the color gradient is different or
it's a different kind of
uh memory arcane spirit
double charge up on that
magic sword
that was a
back-to-back jump attack
he's definitely a little bit stronger
than ours
there's the dragon head attack that he
has taken in a zone for power
now mixing his
acrobatics with the fire the dragon
that looks like it did a lot of damage
actually
okay so note
everything back here there's like a
little torch or something but it's not
on fire or anything
now keep an eye on the area behind it
smashes us and then it looks like
there's some fire going over back here
looks like it emits behind him as well
because then there's fire exploding
behind him back here over here which is
really far away
like just pumes of fire
plumes i guess i should say a fire going
everywhere
this seems completely like a separate
area or separate like
not touching him at all
[Music]
more details will be revealed at a later
date more details there's not
in the meantime we greatly appreciate
your continued support
all right and then they have a kind of
rendition of the original trailer i
think like slightly just edited a bit
differently um lands between call your
name
uh yeah
and
looks pretty cool i'm sure the rest of
the community will do really in-depth
analysis on all of this
i
am going to be busy so i will probably
not be posting a video looking more
in-depth at it maybe if there's
something that stands out um but just
like reporting on gameplay doesn't seem
as
interesting to me
um though there's one thing that i just
saw
uh is
this so this little
it looks like a scarecrow
is
launching magic attacks at a big guy
that does not look like you
that is definitely not you i don't know
what this interaction is about
um
yeah
so i will let this serve as my
reaction and analysis i think it looks
really cool um i'm very excited the
gameplay that all looked pretty
promising to me um obviously small
snippets but nonetheless look pretty
pretty good
and all the people that came out watched
i appreciate it i don't not a big
streamer so
cool to try it out a little bit um do
some
a cool reaction uh or just see some cool
cons i don't know if my reaction is cool
yeah all right i'm gonna gonna be ending
stream so
again thanks everyone for coming out all
you lurkers
and
see you
whatever other elden ring or other
uh
content come out with and if any you
don't know i made a dark souls uh
video recently so be sure to go check
that out it's a little bit more meta
um
as opposed to like my lower videos but
it's
like looking at cool aspects of dark
souls and
uh
the philosophy of
video games which i know people love
alright thanks for watching peace